welcome to this video playing taxi taxi
this is Cuba hmm don't think so but it's
similar it's Cuba okay I got one right
let's see maybe go for con you please
default yes the good thing about the
Condors it doesn't have so many flossing
lines you can you can play it without
knowing so much concrete stuff not only
a four okay not so familiar with this
against this particular line let's see
norley Air Force always a bit tricky
because it it weakens we can see form
yeah now i'm very tempted to quickly
push the h-bond this is quite often a
really good idea okay let's let's do
that the bishop won't be 70 my idea is
to push even further h3y are dead the
King on h1 is serve in this sensitive
diagonal okay interesting I'd like to
play night h 593 if possible of course
let's prepare that of course there are
all kinds of possible sacrifices now but
if you don't want to
risk some of those sacrifices you you're
better off playing the petrol for some
other more classical opening yeah
possible ideas for example e5 takes
Knight xe6 this could be quite dangerous
but only five I could also maybe I could
complain at age five and once i have
class old long i can play maji three and
win material I is taking some time I'm
expecting some kind of sacrifice now
there's also f-5e 596 those kind of
ideas also possible I don't think it's
working at this particular in this
particular position but then have to
check all that he's taking lots of time
I hope is not disconnected would be a
good pointless then no he's connected
yeah now he's coming up with the the
move I'm had egg had expected really
okay if I take here only five he's going
to play 96 no doubt about that takes
bishop g6 check King d8 i'm not really
seeing why this is so great maybe he
just recaptures night takes and then I
don't know a second e six or bishop I
form and possible okay okay 92
I need to blame you could spend early
ages here trying to work out the correct
way to play but you won't succeed just
trying to get some ideas going on my own
I g3 but this is of course only working
if I have casted long yeah that's the
first clear no no time to it cannot
waste at any time that's what I'm trying
to say but he's not threatening
something at the moment g7 is covered
and c7 discovered but on what I must do
and I need to connect rooks somehow
maybe look aged 6 this is a very strange
rules maybe maybe 93 is a threat and
then ok now after that his is it he's
got a detector hmm that's a shame
okay I cannot calculate him impossible
just too much going on tix with Brooke
why not why not very tricky yeah but I
thought long castles I need to I need to
get get out get out of all of this now
try for counterplay I have night afore i
had night f form this was probably very
strong him hmm
yeah just once one I mr. critical moment
this is what's the the golden
opportunity ya know I'm probably just
losing ah what a shame don't I don't see
any any thing close to a defense just
like a form
yeah he's threatening to take on this
and i cannot i must play crap move like
that yeah yeah i had this one chance
that's not going to pop up again this
opportunity yeah you know even this this
nonsense okay ah how disappointed I'm
yeah of course was a total mess and
probably winning for black but who is
going to to figure that all out yeah the
computer says white is winning here this
may be true but not the position
afterwards I don't I don't think so why
not night night air force not good
Bishop g2 what is the big point I Scott
92 okay he's got 92 okay yeah I didn't
see that when L it was was lost anyway
yeah it's very tricky disposition maybe
I cannot afford it should be seven and
now a five it's am obviously a very a
very tricky position maybe long castles
but yeah of course it's a position that
can easily blow up in your face and then
this is just wrong yeah yeah I was a bit
too optimistic he'll and then he played
a really good game alright thanks for
watching